I live in the quarterback film room at
One Gillette Stadium
My name is Tom Brady. I'm 40 years old
I believe in taking care of myself
in a self-branded diet and achieving
sustained peak performance
In the morning, if my face is a little puffy
I'll put on an ice pack modified with my $200
smartphone app that combines vague inspirational
quotes with brain games meant for old people
I'll then apply anti-aging organic eyeblack made from
the ashes of Jimmy Garoppolo's contract extension
Gisele was wrong
One day I WILL throw AND catch the ball
I work in the National Football League
Let's see Rodgers' card
Oh my god
Look at that subtle mobility
Tom, are you OK?
I have all the characteristics of a human being
but not a single, clear, identifiable emotion
Why are your floors covered with the
newspapers of your Super Bowl losses?
Besides KILL, KILL, KILL!